in this course you'll learn how to use
corus and jpa streamer to build a rest
web application corus is an open source
framework tailored for Java optimized
for building Speedy Cloud native
microservices and serverless
applications especially in containerized
environments like kubernetes jpa
streamer on the other hand is a Java
library that simplifies database
interactions by allowing jpa entities to
harness the expressiveness of java
stream operations when combined corus's
rapid startup and minimal memory
footprint works well with jpa streamer
intuitive database quering offering
developers a seamless efficient and
cohesive environment Julia gustofson
teaches this course she is an
experienced Java developer with speed
minint corus provided a grant to make
this course possible hello and welcome
again to the free code Camp YouTube
channel my name is Julia and I'm a Java
developer and today I'm very excited to
be introducing you to two fairly recent
additions to the Java ecosystem corcus
and jpa
streamer so the reason I pair these two
tools up for this tutorial is because I
believe that they have the potential of
changing the way you perceive Java
development and really my hope is for
this tutorial that at the end of it you
will approach Java development with much
more excitement than before so the
reason I'm saying this is because I feel
like in recent years the Java language
has felt a bit outdated in comparison to
something like type script or python
which comes with these environments
where you can recompile your code really
quickly whenever you make a small change
and the nature of the language being
objectoriented and types safe sometimes
got in the way of making it like
intuitive to write and read because you
have to create a lot of objects and
things that may seem unintuitive at the
time and then also of course Java
applications are known to be slow to
start and have a large memory footprint
and that sometimes makes them unsuitable
for cloud
deployment but quirkus is really here to
redraw the map for us because it's an
open source Java development platform
that gives you a lot of value at first
go so unlike many other platforms
quirkus doesn't come with a steep
learning curve you can really write your
applications as normal but it's the
build process which is completely
reimagine and that means you're going to
be able to restart your application in a
split second whenever you're developing
using the quirkus dev mode and you're
also going to be able to perform
continuous testing without the tests
getting in the way your productivity and
finally once you're ready for deployment
the native build capabilities of corkus
is going to boost your performance
significantly both in terms of the
startup time and it's going to reduce
your memory footprint by a lot to show
off cor is I'm going to be taking you
along while developing a rest web
application from scratch on the corcus
platform and that's going to be reading
data from a film database using
hibernate and jpa streamer so JP
streamer is the second component that I
would like to introduce you to today
today and that's because it addresses
the other problem that I mentioned about
Java being sometimes wordy and
unintuitive so basically JP streer is an
extension for hybernate that doesn't
impact how you would use hybernate
normally but it does extend the API with
the capability to express your queries
as Java streams so what that means is
that you can use the stream API as a way
of expressing your SQL query and upon
execution it will be automatically
translated to SQL to ensure that it's
still efficiently executed in the
database rather than in the
jbm during development I'm going to be
showing you all the relevant features of
both corkus and JP streamer and at the
end of it all I'm sure you're going to
have enough knowledge to go out and
utilize these tools on your own if you
enjoy them as much as I do but before we
get into coding I want to provide you
with a little bit more background on
what makes quirkus and JP streamers such
good
libraries so quirkus was initiated by
red hat but being being an open source
project it has grown a lot since with
contributions from various individuals
and other
organizations I often see described as a
cuttingedge cloud native framework
that's tailored to the needs of both
Java and cotlin applications but why is
this important today well its mission is
really to tackle some of the challenges
that have shadowed Java in recent years
because Java has struggled a bit to fit
into the modern Cloud environments and
that is not to say that Java isn't a
great development language it's just a
result of the fact that at the time Java
came about there was different
priorities you were used to building
monoliths that would just deployed and
ran for extended periods of time but
then came the cloud environments and now
we need to be much more concerned with
the amount of resources for application
consumes otherwise it's going to get
really expensive and if we consider
serverless we need to be really
concerned with the startup times because
we don't want our clients to wait
several seconds for application to
respond but the Great thing is that with
corkus you can actually say goodbye to
Long application startup periods the
high memory consumption and to some
extent even the rather slow development
experience in my opinion now is also a
really good time to learn corkus because
as it's been maturing for the past few
years all of the major Java libraries
has become available on the corkus
platform so that means you can use
hibernate spring junit and all of those
libraries just like you're used to doing
for some developers the lower startup
times and the model application
footprint is definitely going to be
perceived as the main perks of corkus
but for me personally the biggest
advantage of corkus is really the
life-changing developer mode I've always
envied no developers who can rebuild
their applications in a split second
when they're making these small
incremental changes to an app so when I
first tried the quirkus live reload
feature I was just thrilled to learn
that Java developers can also enjoy such
a fluid development experience and as
you'll see later on all the changes that
I apply to my applications are reflected
immediately and I don't ever have to
wait for the application to make a full
restart before I can validate that
things are
working so as part of the demonstration
of the corcus platform I also wanted to
show you a library that you may not have
heard of before but that is really
useful in the context of database
applications and it's called jpa
streamer like corkus jpa streamer is
also an open source project but this one
was initiated by per mbor who is
actually working full-time as an oracle
core Java developer today and this is a
library that simplifies database access
in Java applications that uses the Java
persistence API or jpa so it can pretty
much be viewed as a lightweight
hibernate extension that will extend the
API of your existing application to
include this really expressive and
typesafe stream query API that makes the
coding experience much less error prone
and it will help increase your
productivity so to better understand
what JP streamer is doing I'm going to
show you this example because this is a
stream query that will fetch 10 films
from a database each starting with a
letter a and are at least 1 hour long
can you see how simple that is to
read so critics will say that this is
going to be the same as using
hibernate's built-in method get result
stream and then just apply the same
stream pipeline but there is actually a
fundamental difference in working with
streams in the current hibernate API and
working with jpa streamer because if you
call get res stream to stream an entire
table you're going to materialize every
entity and that can get very expensive
if your table is big but with JB
streamer your pipeline is going to be
translated to an hql query and that
ensures that only the resulting entities
are materialized as if you were using
SQL all along so hopefully this made you
inspired to follow along and learn
quirkus and JP streamer in the upcoming
tutorial so to follow along you're going
to need a basic understanding of how to
use Java and Java streams and I'm also
going to expect that you have worked
with SQL and some kind of jpa Provider
such as hibernate before so that you
understand how to set up the jpa
entities because I'm not going to be
going over hibernate in any
detail your Dev environment also needs
to comply with these requirements so
we're working with Java 11 that's the
earliest release of java that's
compatible with quirkus and jpa streamer
you're also going to need some kind of
build tool in my case I'm using a recent
version of Maven so that's going to be
Maven
391 but if you're more comfortable
working with Gradle I'm sure you're
going to be able to adapt many of the
steps to Gradle instead the same goes
for your IDE you're free to choose
whatever you like of course but I'm
working with intellig and it's going to
be easier to follow along if you're
using intellig as well the final
requirement is Docker because I'm going
to be using a sample database that's
available as a Docker image Docker is
also going to be used for the native
compilation Step at the end but you can
also choose to install grow VM locally
rather than using the grvm
distribution so with that covered we're
going to start building our applications
so next up is the project
setup once you have your jdk and IDE
ready it's time to create a new corcus
project and there are a couple ways you
can do this either using the corcus
command line interface leveraging your
ide's corcus integration or using the
corcus project
configurator to keep the number of
installations down to minimum I will
refrain from using the corkus command
line inter face in this video although I
do recommend that you check it out if
you wish to continue using quirkus in
future
projects configuring the project in
intell has worked really well for me in
the past but if you want to make sure
that you find all available corkus
extensions I recommend that you use the
corus project configurator as I will do
here the project configurator is
available on the corkus website so
that's corkus doio and you find it under
the start coding tab on top here so this
page is going to going to allow us to
configure our project and that means
naming it selecting what build tool to
use what Java version and also adding in
any dependencies that we need for the
application we also need to select a
corcus version and in this case I would
be sticking with the latest one which is
3.2 3.2 also happens to be a long-term
supported release which means it's going
to be maintained for a long time since
we're using hibernate for the database
integration I also just want to note
that quirkus 3 is compatible with
hibernate 6 and later for anyone
starting out fresh that's not really
going to have any implications I'm
simply saying that because there may be
someone watching who has hibernate code
in an existing project that they wish to
reuse and in that case just pay
attention to any breaking changes
between hibernate 5 and six when you
import that
code moving ahead I'm going to give my
project a group ID of org. freec cod
camp and an artifact ID of corkus
tutorial
as my build tool I'm going to stick with
Maven simply because that's what I'm
most used to working with but you can
also choose grle for example if that's
what you prefer looking at the other
options here I'm going to stick with the
version number and I'll be selecting
Java 17 as my Java version I'm also
deselecting the starter code option
simply because I know what application
I'm going to build and I don't need a
template for it otherwise if you select
a dependency that has starter code that
will be included in the zip file that
you download so now we can go ahead and
add in our dependencies and as the
application will be using a mySQL
database I'm going to start off by
adding the jdbc driver for
MySQL next I'm going to go ahead and add
our GP provider which in this case is
hibernate with a flavor of panach and
panach is corcus specific so therefore
if you're a hybernate user but never
heard of panage you should just know
that you can still write your hibernate
applications just the same way you would
in a regular job application but panach
comes with some really neat
features so next we're going to need the
rest EC Jackson dependency as that will
allow us to create rest end points very
quickly and let's not forget about jpa
streamer that I introduced in the
beginning of the video which is going to
allow us to express our queries as Java
streams and finally I'm adding in small
R open API which is going to allow us to
use Swagger to test our endpoints
so now that I have all the dependencies
I'll just go ahead and click generate
your application to download a project
zip
folder then I'll just go ahead and unzip
that folder to reveal the contents and
as you can tell it contains the palom
XML which indicates that this is a maven
project so I'll be opening it up in
intellig and I'm just going to start by
expanding my window to full size and
then I'm selecting
open and I'm locating the pom XML file
because in my experience this works well
when importing Maven projects so I'll
open that as a project and intell will
automatically add it as a maven project
for me so the first thing you'll see is
a read me which contains some
instructions on how to run your
application with corkus but as we're
going through this together I'm not
going to show you that now instead we're
going to look in the sources directory
and you can tell that there's an empty
Java
folder and if we peek into the pom XML
file we find the dependencies I just
selected including corcus itself
hibernate with panach jpa streamer and
the jtbc driver at the bottom here you
can also see that the testing Library
junit 5 was automatically added for us
in the testing scope so our project is
mostly set up but we're missing a very
important piece of infrastructure which
is the
database so when I play around with new
technologies I often find it useful to
use something like a sample database
base just to get up and running quickly
and in this case I'm going to be using
the seila database which is provided for
free by Oracle the Aila database doesn't
have a very descriptive name but it
models an old-fashioned video rental
store like the ones where you would
actually bring your film home on tape or
DVD and as you can expect most Central
to the database in this case is the film
table but there are various other tables
that support the overall business of
renting out films such as inventory
customer and payment
for this application though I'm going to
be focusing on films and the actors that
star in those films almost as if we were
building an IMDb like service therefore
our job application is also going to
have to model the actor table and the
film actor table which represents the
many to Mena relationships between films
and actors because a film can star many
actors and an actor can star in many
films the database is available as a
Docker image on Docker Hub so I'm just
going to be using Docker run to download
and spin up the image in a container as
I've used this database many times
before I happen to know that it was
actually built for Linux amd64
infrastructure and I'm currently on an
M1 Mac and that means that Docker will
by default go out looking on Docker hub
for images that were built for my
platform meaning the
M1 in my experience the image still
works fine on the M1 I just need to
force Docker to accept Linux images by
adding the platform flag and specify the
Linux amd64
platform the D flag will detach this
process from my terminal once it's up
and running and I will publish my
runting service on Port 3306 here making
a mapping between the internal and
external
ports I will name the running container
seila and finally I specify the name of
the image that I want to fetch namely
rest SQL MySQL sakila so running this
command you can see that the image is
being downloaded as a wasn't located
locally and then finally once the image
is pulled the container is started great
if you have Docker desktop installed you
can also try opening up the app and
looking under containers to just confirm
that the container seems to be up and
running and in this case our cila
container is there and it's looking
healthy before we go on I usually think
it's helpful to kind of inspect what's
in the database so I'm using intell to
connect to it selecting data source and
MySQL as that's our database
type and this will pop up this dialogue
and I just need a few settings firstly
the username is root and the password is
sakila the name of the database and I'm
also specifying here in the connection
string that the name is sakila and the
port is 3306 which is
correct let's see if it connects yeah
perfect it found it so then let's look
at the contents H okay so this often
happens to me in and what usually works
is just making a
refresh of the databased content so yeah
perfect that
worked opening that up we can see that
we have 23 tables and that includes of
course the film table which is Central
to our app that has the film ID as its
primary key and a number of other values
associated with films and I'm just going
to open that up real quick because this
database contains totally made of movies
and it seems like the person who came up
with these descriptions had quite a fun
time take this one for example Fair
Prejudice the description reads a
fancyful documentary we have a frisbey
and a lumberjack who must chase a monkey
in a shark tank well this would have
been easy with chat TPT but I'm pretty
sure that this database far predates
it so if we also have a look into the
acture table you'll see that we find
lots more of these half madeup names how
about zero cage
well and apart from first and last name
we have an actor ID that acts as the
primary
key then finally as I mentioned before
there's one table that defines the
relationship between these entities and
that's called film and actor and in here
you just find actor IDs and film IDs so
that's foreign keys to the other tables
now our goal is of course not to just
view this data in intelly we really want
to serve this up and be able to
manipulate it via some endpoints so next
we're going to need to make hibernate
aware of our database and we do that by
setting up the configuration and the
configuration resides in the resources
folder as you can see here it's called
application properties and this is
really the corkus configuration files so
that means anything Quirk is related
that needs configuration is going to be
done in here it's also good to know that
the database config that we're going to
apply can be picked up by any dependency
that needs a database so that means
means the configuration is not going to
be specific to
hibernate however it is pretty similar
to what we did before when connecting to
the database and intellig we just first
need to specify what jdbc driver to use
and in this case again it's a mySQL
database so that means we're using the
MySQL driver which we have on the class
path we're also specifying our jdbc
connection URL and that's referring to
Local Host 3306 where the database is
running and then we pass along the user
name which is root and the password
which is
sakila finally I would like to tell
hibernate to log every query that we
issue in the database and that's simply
because it's going to be easier to
follow when we use jpa streamer to see
what queries it
renders okay so far we've only been
concerned with the setup but now we're
going to move on to the fun part which
is coding so in the next section I'll be
creating the entity classes and setting
up the jpa repository so saying that we
were going to start coding was almost a
lie because I'm actually going to use
intellig to generate the jpa entities
and the reason I prefer to do it this
way is because I tend to avoid writing
boilerplate and in the case of jpa
entities it's mostly just beans with
Getters and Setters so I generate the
bulk of the code that I need and then I
adjust it slightly to fit my needs so
I'll revisit the database tab on the top
right here and right click on my
database and on the bottom I have the
option of generating a persistence
mapping and then I just specify in what
package I would like to place the
generated entities and start by
deselecting all the tables because I
simply want to generate entities for the
actor table and the film
table and lastly I make sure that the
option generate jpa annotations is
selected as you can see my entities were
placed in the package that I spef speci
ified and if I open up the film class I
see that I have mappings for each and
every one of my columns and this is
going to cover most of our needs for
this application but there's a ton of
annotations that you can use to
customize these entities further however
as this is not a full course on
hibernate I'm just going to show you
what we need to get this application
working and one of the columns that
needs better specification is the
ratings column and by rating I don't
refer to a rating on a 1 to 10 scale
like a one you would see on Rotten
Tomatoes but rather the recommended age
rating so going back to our database
view again on the right we can see that
the ratings column holds an enum that
can take on five different values G PG
PG-13 R and
nc17 by adding this information to our
column definition we're going to help
hybernate the values of the
database
for
now the rest of the columns we can leave
as is and I just need to add one more
annotation to our entity as a whole
because I know that hibernate will need
to know what table this entity maps to
and in this case that's a table called
film in the schema seila and then I need
to open up the actra table and add the
same table annotation to this class but
now I'll specify that the entity maps to
the actor table but the schema name is
of course the
same I also know that intell hasn't
helped me to specify the relationship
between these two tables so I'm just
going to go ahead and add that manually
as I mentioned before they have a many
to many relationship and this is going
to be described mainly by the field
actor in the film table I'm going to set
that up in a second and to be able to
interact with the films that an actor
starson I'm going to set up this field
which is a set of all the films that
this actress starson and this field also
needs a getter and Setter in order for
it to be read or updated and next I'm
going to have to go back to the film
table to make a more detailed
specification of this join or this
relationship so again this is not a jpa
tutorial and I will not explain
everything that's going on here there
are much greater resources on how to
express jpa relationships and I
recommend that you check them out if you
want to learn more about this specific
topic but in short I just need to
specify the fact that film actor is our
joint table and then I'm saying that my
film entities are characterized by the
main join column which is the film ID
and secondly as my invers join column
I'll say that I'm referencing the
primary key in the actor table which is
actor ID and I'm going to facilitate
interactions with the actors that star
in a film with a list of
actors and just as in the case of the
actor table I'm going to create Getters
and Setters for this field so that we
can read it and update
it that completes the creation of the
jpa entity model and from that we're
going to go ahead and generate the jpa
streamer meta model so why the need of
two meta models you may ask well that's
a good question but it has to do with
the fact that JB streamer is going to
translate your stream pipelines into SQL
queries and in order to do that it needs
some extra meta information uh about the
columns basically that you wish to
query so as you may have noticed a
pipeline like this could have been
expressed using regular lambdas but
those lambdas are quite Anonymous and
doesn't contain any information about
the database columns that we need at all
so looking at this query that I showed
you previously you can notice the
presence of a film dollar sign entity
and that is part of the jpa streamer
meta model and will expose any fields
that belongs to that table so that you
can easily construct these predicates
which are interpretable by JP
streamer luckily though generating this
meta model is as easy as rebuilding your
application so let's do
it once your application has been
rebuilt it's going to place the meta
model in the Target folder and as you
can see here an extra entity has been
generated from both the film and actor
entity usually however this folder is
not considered a source folder in
intellig so you have to manually mark it
as a generated sources
route by doing so we ensure that these
classes will be made available to the
application I should also note that the
jpa streamer documentation contains
instructions for how to place these
generated classes in a different package
or to name them something else than just
The Entity named followed by a dollar
sign but I'll leave that for you to
check out if that's something you want
to
do so that finishes the section on meta
models and now we can go ahead and build
our application and just as a bit of a
reminder the goal here is to provide a
number of endpoints that serves
information about films to clients so
I'm going to structure this application
using a repository pattern simply
because I think that does a good job of
separating the data layer from the rest
of the application
so here's an overview of what the
architecture will look like once we're
done starting from the bottom we have
the sakila database and it's going to be
the repository layer just above that
that is going to handle all the database
interactions in the Java realm our
resource class on top of the repository
is going to define the rest end points
and we'll call the repository whenever
it needs some information from the
database so that means any requests
performed by the clients are going to
Cascade down the hierarchy hit the
database and go back up to the client so
all in all a very basic architecture
nothing really strange here but it's
still a very effective and useful way of
structuring your applications and with
that overview I think we're ready to
start implementing our film repository
and film
resource so I'm starting by creating my
film resource and please ignore my
mistake of placing this in the model
package I would rather move it one level
up but I discovered it after recording
the entire tutorial but as it doesn't
impact the functionality at all I'm just
going to leave it and go ahead with
implementing this class I'm using
decarta to Define my rest endpoints and
by annotating this class with the path
annotation my application will
automatically pick up the end points
that I'm going to Define in here I'm
leaving the base path empty simply
because I'm only having one resource in
this
application so there's no better way to
test something out than creating a hello
world base case right so that's what
we're doing it's not creative it's not
original but at least it's a good way to
just see that we get the basic concepts
so here I'm creating a get endpoint that
is available at the path hello world and
it will return a simple text string so
basically we're just returning hello
world so with that we just defined our
first endpoint and I'm going to go ahead
and fire up the quirkus development mode
so that we can test that everything is
working as we
expect so the read me that we got from
our template contains instructions on
how to run the development mode and as
you can tell the command is pretty
simple
mvnw compile quirkus Dev and it takes a
little while to fire
up okay seems like something's
malfunctioning let's see what that
is okay great we got some instant
feedback from hibernate saying that
there's something wrong with our jpa
model
specifically the special features
field oh apparently I said this was an
enum it's actually a set I
believe yeah okay so it's a set of
features that's allowed not just one so
we're just going to go ahead and change
that and if I go down to my terminal and
press S I will restart the
application and now it works since I
haven't specified any ports it's running
on the default port 8080 however the
base URL does not contain any content so
the corkus demoe desperately tries to
provide me with other options including
a link to Swagger UI and if you haven't
heard of swagger it's a really neat tool
that I recommend if you're working with
rest applications simply because it
picks up or detects all the available
endpoints and allow you to test them
interactively in the browser so
thankfully it picked up our hello world
endpoint and since it doesn't accept any
parameters I'm just going to execute it
and see what it says hm our response
body contains hello world so that's all
good and now I'm just going to take the
opportunity to show you just how easy it
is to make incremental changes to your
applications that are instantly detected
by corcus so in this case I'm just
adding a second hell World
endpoint I'm restarting the application
by pressing s on the keyboard returning
to my browser refreshing the page
and there we go I have a second endpoint
just like that and again I can execute
it and you can see that it returns hello
world 2 and this live reload feature is
the thing I love most about corus I
believe simply because it's just so nice
to be able to stay in the Flow by
avoiding these 3 to 5c latencies every
time you need to rebuild and restart
your application
manually okay back to the practice of
show don't tell so I'm just about to set
up my first real endpoint but to do that
I first need to create the film
repository that is going to serve
content from the database and again I
wish I place this repository package one
level up but we're going to ignore it
again so here's our film repository and
since we're using jpa streamer for our
queries I just start by injecting a jpa
streamer instance to give us a handle
for our queries I'm then starting out
really simple by creating a and point
that can be used to fetch a film given
its ID so the reason we're having an
optional as a return value is that we're
only going to populate this value if we
find a film with a matching ID so now
it's time to use jpa streamer in our
application and our first query is going
to remind you of the example that I
showed earlier and we're basically just
going to query the film table and look
for films with a matching ID and
considering the ID is the primary key
there can only be one such film so if we
find anything that's the value we return
just like with a SQL query the jpa
streamer query starts with the a select
statement or in this case JP streamer
stream film class which says that we're
interested in streaming the film
entities and the stream that this method
returns is a standard Java Stream So any
operations that can be applied to Java
stream can be applied to this stream
however you need to be a bit mindful
about the fact that JP streamer can only
translate jpa streamer predicates
efficiently and not regular lambdas but
they're not hard to use and I'll show
you how that's done if you're used to
SQL queries this would have been a worse
statement but in the realm of streams
we're applying a filter to check if the
column film ID matches the given film
ID and using the databased rumor meta
model is generally not any harder than
this you simply just specify which
column you would like to use for your
predicate and all of the common
operators for comparisons are available
the execution of the query is delayed
until we apply a terminal operator and
in this case I'm using find first so
with a query in place I want to go ahead
and create an endpoint that allow
clients to fetch films based on their
IDs so I need to start by injecting my
film repository so that I can call the
method I just created and from there I
create an mpoint much like the ones we
already have but with the one exception
that I'm going to take in a parameter
and that's done by placing a variable
name inside curly brackets like
this making sure that your method here
accepts a parameter that shares the same
name that it knows what to match it to
and now we just simply need to call the
method we just created but since we're
getting back an optional I'm going to
check if there is any value present
because if there isn't then I know that
there was no film in the database with a
matching
ID so if a film is present then I'll get
that and I'm just going to print the
title and otherwise I'll just print a
message saying that there was no
matching
film okay so let's test that we'll
restart our application oops I thought
so um corus is again telling me
something is
wrong
okay I miss the fact that when I want to
inject my film repository here I need to
make sure that it has an annotation that
allows it to be injected so in this case
I'll be using application scope to
indicate that regardless of how many
other classes that injects this class I
want there to be only one instance of it
even intellig seems to think that this
looks more healthy so restarting it
again looks much
better so back to Swagger to test this
out this time I have to provide a film
ID so why not try it with the
35 and apparently that has a title that
I won't even try to pronounce but it
contains the word roller coaster and I
can go back to my database and intell
and look if this seems to be
correct so opening up the film table
scrolling down to 35 oh there it is all
seems to work if you pay attention to
the terminal logs now you can see that
our application has printed the query
that was issued by JP streamer but we're
going to take a closer look at that in
just a
second I've already started here on our
next query and that's going to be a
paged one so we're basically going to
look for films that are at least a
certain length and then we're going to
return the results in a paged manner so
our page size is going to be
20 and we're creating the stream much
like before we're streaming the film
class meaning the film
table and we're applying a filter to
check whether the length is at least the
minimum
length so length greater than Min
length and then to achieve our paging
I'm going to skip a certain number of
results in this case the page I want to
access times the page size and you may
notice that this is going to be a zero
index paging
and then we'll limit our results to our
page
size and just for fun we're also going
to sort the films according to their
length so to test this out I'm going to
need another endpoint so let's go back
to our film resource and craft another
endpoint in this case I'm calling it
page
films and I'm taking in the page number
and the minimum length
and again it produces just plain
text
so this time we don't need to look for
any optional values we're simply going
to stream any results we get back and
format
them
so once we get a list of films back from
our page query we are mapping each film
to their title and their length so that
we can check that we're actually sorting
them according to the sort order and
also that we don't get back any films
that are shorter than the specified
length and then I'm using the terminal
operator collect and I'm collect using
the joining operator and I'll make a
line break between each of the
results okay so we're going to restart
our application again to test this
out and this time it all seems to work
right from the start good so our new
endpoint is detected by
Swagger and I'm providing a minimum
length of 1 hour and let's go with page
three
three perfect here we have a list of
films and none of them is shorter than 1
hour and they're sorted and if we check
out page
four yeah we get longer films which is
what we expected but now let's go back
and look at our query that was issued in
the
database so even though we expressed our
query as a Java stream this is what's
being executed on the back end we have
our rare predicate checking for the
length condition and our sword operator
expressed as an ordered by on the SQL
end but you may notice that we're
selecting all of the columns but we're
only really printing two so I think we
can do a bit better here by making a
projection to only fetch the columns
that we're interested
in so to do this I'll have to modify my
query slightly and in this case I'm
going to modify the stream Source
because in our select state I'm going to
make a projection instead and that
projection is going to refer to the two
columns that I'm interested in but it
also needs to have the primary key which
is the
ID we also need to have a matching
Constructor for our film object because
when JP streamer gets these three values
back it doesn't know how to populate the
other
fields so you're going to see here that
if we just try to run
this with again a minimum length of 1
hour and page number
three we get an exception saying that
there's no matching constructure and one
or more arguments were not
defined so this is easy to resolve by
just making sure that our film entity
here has a Constructor that matches the
arguments that we're going to pass in so
in this case we need a Constructor that
accepts the ID the
title and the
length and then we just simply initiate
our uh Fields with these
values and that should work but we'll
see what happens if we try it
again okay so our results look the same
as before but what about our query did
anything change on the sequel
side yes great so now we're only
selecting the three fields of Interest
meaning we're saving ourselves from
fetching a lot of data that we're just
going to throw away
anyway so for our third query we're
going to make a join because now I'm
interested not only in the films but
also the actors that star in those films
and if I want to fetch information about
the actors that relates to certain film
I need to join in the actor table so in
this case our join is constructed with a
stream configuration and that's
basically just a way of saying that we
want to fetch the film table still but
we want to join in all their Associated
actors and if you remember from before
our film entity has annotations that
describes this join already so we really
only have to say that we're now
interested in joining in these objects
and then we simply replace what used to
be our film class with this new stream
configuration that describes a slightly
more complex stream source and from here
we're free to manipulate our film
entities just as we did previously so
first applying a filter here to check
for films with a title that starts with
a past in
string and then I'm going to sort these
films again according to their length
but this time I'll reverse the order
just to show you how easy it is to do
that and that's all I'm going to do for
this query so again I'm copying this
time the other endpoint and making small
modifications to it so accepting a
starts with
value passing that
in and then calling my new join
method but this time the formatting is
going to be a bit more complex because I
have a stream of films and I'm GNA start
by printing out the again the title of
the film followed by its length and then
I will list all the actors that stars in
the
film so the first value here is going to
correspond to the title and secondly the
length but then my film actor field
actually returns a list of actors so to
print that I'm going to stream over the
list of
actors and I'm going to map each of the
actors to their first name and last
name so just simply concatenating
together those
values and then joining them with the
collector
operator separated by
commas
and finally I'm again joining all my
film entities separated by line
breaks okay so simple restart of the
application will give me access to my
newest member of the rest endpoint
family and I'm trying it with the
character
a and here we get back a list of all the
films that starts with an a and you can
see all the actors that relates to those
films and now again if we go back to
look at the query you can see that the
join is being applied in the SQL
query and of course I'm not saying that
you should come back to the sequel that
JP streamer generates every time but I
do recommend it as a great way of
understanding what JB streer does
especially if you're starting out and
want to understand what your pipelines
are being translated to especially if
you're working with large data sets in
which case the performance is going to
be critical and you may have to optimize
your queries in certain
ways so before we move on I'm just going
to show you quickly how easy it is to
combine multiple predicates so here I'm
just combining both of the predicates
that we worked with before checking that
our title starts with a certain string
and also checking that the length meets
a certain
condition and for that to be effective
on the rest endpoint side I'm just
adding that second parameter
here
restarting and
testing so let's do two hours now and an
a as our star character
again
yeah we don't get back anything shorter
than 2 hours but let's make it a bit
more restrictive so that it's easier to
see that we're actually getting the
right
results yeah nothing's shorter than 170
minutes and all of them start with
a I'm also going to show you how you can
actually use JB streammer to filter out
films you would like to
update so we can in this case up update
the rental rate of our films and the
rental rate is of course what you would
charge to rent out one of the
movies for demonstration purposes we're
going to use a rather unconventional
algorithm in this case so we're going to
set the price of the movies that are
longer than a given
length oh I also just recall that the
type of rental rate is actually a
float so updating the movies that match
this griven predicate is really simple
you just again use datas streumer to
select the films of interest and then
apply the for each operator to set a new
rental rate of each of the movies that
remain in the
pipeline and that's really all there's
to it but before I create another
endpoint to facilitate these updates I'm
going to create a small utility method
for my response value that just sends
back all the movies that have been
updated and their newest
price so again just creating a stream of
all the films filtering them to make
sure that they are longer than the given
length and then sorting them by
length Okay so for some reason this is
not compiling found an extra parenthesis
there perfect so this is going to be our
final endpoint and in this case we are
actually going to perform updates so
let's make sure that what we just did is
working so I'm naming this one update
and then I'm accepting a minimum length
and a new rental rate
you know the drill by now
right just updating my method
parameters so I'm just going to start of
course by updating the
prices by calling the method update
rental rate that we just
created and then we'll call the utility
method to return back all the movies
that should have been affected by our
update so just get the films of a
certain minimum length and then I'm
updating my string formatting here to
include the rental rate as well so that
we can see the new
price okay restarting the application
let's see how this
goes my new endpoint is there looking
all
good so now let's just update a few of
the really long ones so minimum length
of 170 and a rental rate of
$10 okay so I see no price change
whatsoever and this could be explained
by two things either we didn't make any
updates at all or the updates were not
reflected in my second query just
fetching the films again but we're going
to take a look okay so looking in the
database none of the prices have
actually changed so that means my update
wasn't effective at all and I must admit
I did this intentionally just to point
out that your updates are not going to
have an effect unless you apply the
keyword transactional to your your
update method so The transactional
annotation here indicates that we would
like to persist any updates that we make
on our film entities in this
method so if all goes well this should
fix our
problem and thankfully it did so now you
can see that our updates have taken
effect and the new price of our movies
is
$10 and if we now go back to the
database it's going to be a different
story because this time I'm sure that
the prices are reflected okay first
update yeah there we go our new prices
are showing so up until now we've been
testing the application manually just
going back and forth to the database
printing things and this is of course
not the way to do testing this is way
too error prone so corkus has this
really cool feature built into its
development mode that allows you to
create tests that are run every time
basically your application is restarted
and that way you get instant feedback on
whether or not things are working the
way you intended them to so with that
said let's go on to make some continuous
junit
tests so if youve been following long
from start using the corkus starter page
then you should be all set up in terms
of dependencies but I'm just going to
restate what is needed to get the
continuous testing working the way I'm
going to show you now so first off you
need to have the porus junit 5
dependency and this should be
automatically added for you but if you
don't have it make sure to add it and as
a final less obvious step you need to
set your Maven Shire plug-in version and
that is because the default version does
not come with support for junit 5 so
make sure you set it to something recent
in this case I'm using
3.00 from this point on testing is
really not much different from creating
your regular Jun tests so to start I
just need to create the standard Maven
test folder which which didn't exist
from
before and then I'm going to go ahead
and create a film resource test since I
will be testing out our rest end
points then to have them run
automatically when you rebuild your
application I'm applying The annotation
quirkus
test and from here I'm sticking with the
Jun annotation test to create my first
test of the rest endpoint hello world
as we're testing rest end points I also
want to take the opportunity to show you
a really convenient Library that's
specifically designed to test end points
this is of course totally optional but
if you want to use it then add the
dependency rest assured just as I'm
doing here and I'm also going to put it
in the test scope since I don't need it
for my
application so rest assured in
combination with corkus is really
powerful since this will allow you to
run integration tests T only by
specifying what the endpoint is that you
would like to call what parameters to
call it with and then Define the
expected result so here I'm saying that
I want to call the endpoint film with an
ID of
343 and then I expect the status code to
be okay namely 200 and I also expect
that my body contains a certain string
in this case I'm expecting it to contain
the title of that film and I just need
to quickly check in the database what
I'm really expecting
here so I'm going over to the film table
looking for it
frantically there it is okay I figured I
might as well pick another ID which is
more easily available so I'm going to
change the ID to five and I'm expecting
it the title to be African
egg so all I need to trigger this test
is to reround my application and you can
see on the bottom that it says press R
to resume testing so I'm pressing the
key R and now it says running one of one
all tests
passed and that's great so that means
the title was actually African egg but I
can add in a second test to also show
you what it looks like if the test is
failing so if again I'm querying the
same
endpoint film with an ID of five and
still expecting the status code to be
200 however I'm going to put in a
different string for the body to show
you that it's going to warn you if it's
wrong so in this case I'm expecting it
to be Titanic pressing R again to rerun
my tests and now we can immediately tell
that something is wrong because we got
back African egg and we were expecting
Titanic so there's a number of aspects
of this that I just find so powerful
since a lot of this tutorial has been
focusing on developer experience again
this is a Fant fantastic example of an
API that is so fluid and smooth to work
with we also didn't have to do any
special
configurations um letting quers know how
to run our services where to find these
endpoints all of that just works out of
the box it will spin up the services for
you on a designated test port and then
execute all of your
tests even though I find this part more
impressive it's also of course really
useful to be able to just perform unit
tests rather than integration tests
so I'm also going to add in a film
repository test and that is just to show
you how you can perform unit testing
meaning in this case we're going to test
the film repository class
directly so again I'm adding in the
corcus test annotation to allow corkus
to pick up my tests and then I'm
injecting my film repository just like
we did earlier for the film
resource and then I can just go ahead
and create a normal junit test where I'm
going to call the film method directly
to get one of the films for Simplicity
I'm using the same argument as before so
that we know that the title of the film
is African
egg but as this method returns an
optional I'm actually first going to
assert that the optional is not empty
meaning there is a value present in this
variable and after that I'll assert that
the title is African EG
okay let's rerun the
tests oh I'm going to get rid of the
failing test in the other class just
to have our output show us that all of
the tests are passing there we go so now
you know how to perform both regular
unit tests and also integration tests
with corkus continuous testing luckily
in this case uh both of our simple tests
were passing but if we discover that one
of our tests were failing and we didn't
know why then it might be useful to use
the debugger that's built in in intell
so next I'm going to show you how you
can attach the debugger to the corkus
dev mode so that you can try your arm
points in Swagger and hit break points
in your code due to the order in which I
was recording this uh we've gotten back
the failing test on top here but let's
ignore that for now and restart our
development mode with an extra flag
namely D debug and that's going to fire
up uh the corcus development mode in
debug
mode so now I'm just going to go ahead
and create a run configuration which
will allow me to attach intellig
debugger to my corcus application so in
this dialogue I need to select the
little plus sign on the top left here to
create a new configuration and in this
case it's going to be a remote jvm debug
so let me just find that option
and the default settings are actually
fine here because uh the corkus log said
that the corus is listening on Port
55 so I'm basically just naming my R
configuration and then uh restart corkus
and also starting my debugging process
in
int and it instantly says that it's been
connected to my target versal machine on
Port
50005 so let's just go ahead and add in
a break point to see that it's all
working so I'm using this simple
endpoint get film and just like before I
can make a request from
Swagger and this should hit my
breakpoint if everything's working out
fine yeah it did I'm pretty sure that
you already know how to use intelligence
debugger from here so I'm not going to
go into any more depth I just wanted to
show you what it looks like working with
intell debugger and the quirkus dev mode
at the same time now that we actually
have a working application I think it's
time to think about how we can improve
the application's
performance because as I stated early on
when introducing corus native
compilation is one of the reasons why
you should consider using this framework
so we're going to have a look at how
much we can improve our startup time um
by building the corcus application in
two different ways the first one is
using the corcus build command and this
is the standard way if you just want to
package your application as a standard
Java
jar and the build process is of course
also going to run the test that we've
created to assure that our application
seems to be
working and once the build process is
done we can find the jar in the Target
folder at the root level here you can
see that there's a corcus tutorial one
snapshot jar and that's your regular
Maven build jar um so that's not
runnable it Just contains all the
classes and resources for your
project however if you look into the
quirkus app folder you can see that
there's is a corkus run jar and that jar
can be used to execute your
application however if you want to
deploy your application somewhere like
in a container then you would have to
deploy the entire corcus app directory
because this jar is not an Uber jar it
doesn't contain all the dependencies
that your application needs to run but
since we have access to this folder now
we can run the application from with
inside that
folder so here I'm just using the
regular Java command to run a jar
file so as the application starts it's
going to tell us how long it took to
fire it up in this case 1.7 seconds
while we're at it I'm also again just
going to test that this works so opening
up Local Host 8080 but this time I'm not
running in the corkus dev mode but
rather um running the actual built
application so an ID of 34 gives us back
Arabia DOA
and the logs are still showing that we
executed a query so the REM file that we
got with our project template actually
contains instructions on how to build
your application natively as well so
there are two versions of this script
the first one uses grvm and the second
is using a container based version of
grvm in case you don't have grvm locally
but since I do have grvm installed I'm
running the First Command you're going
to notice that this takes uh quite a
long time compared to the regular build
but that's totally according to plan
because what we want to achieve when
compiling natively is really to first
off get rid of all the unnecessary
unused code uh which is going to require
some code analysis and grvm is also able
to build up some of the state that we're
going to need at the time when we start
up our application and that's also going
to save us some time here I've been
speeding up the process so you wouldn't
get bored but it took me about 4 and 1/2
minutes to complete the native build and
the result is a runner script that can
be executed just like any other shout
script and you'll find this runner in
the root of your target folder so here
it is corkus tutorial one0 snapshot
Runner so I'm firing that up in my
terminal and immediately you can see
that my application now started in a
tenth of a second so this is a massive
Improvement from what we had before okay
that marks the end of this tutorial and
I would like to thank you so much for
watching I hope you picked up some new
Java skills along the way and I also
hope that you like Java a bit more now
that you've seen what quirkus and date
based RoR can do as a reminder they're
both free to use so I encourage you to
go out and check out their documentation
that is linked in the description below
because there's so much more to discover
that I didn't have time to cover in this
video